القصه الكامله للمنطقه الصيني اللي اسقطته
امريكا فوق اراضيها هو حقيقه اختطاف بلوجر
عراقيه في ليبيا والتسول على تيك توك
ظاهره تحاربها الحكومه الاندونيسيه اهلا
بكم
كلنا نعرف تاريخ العلاقات المتوتره بين
الصين وامريكا واللي زادت من عهد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب واستمرت
لغايه عهد الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن من كم
يوم كانت الاخبار كلها بتتكلم عن تقارب
يعني كان يدوب لسه راح يصير لما نتم
الاعلان عن زياره لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للصين وحتى اخبار كمان عن انه كان راح
يقابل الرئيس الصيني كمان في زياره هذه
لكن كل هذه الاخبار والامال تبخرت من بعد
الملحمه اللي صارت واللي مغطيه على اي
اخبار ثانيه حول العالم طبعا بنتكلم عن
دراما منطاد التجسس الصيني فاللي صار انه
السلطات الامريكيه اعلنت الخميس عن رصد
منطاد صيني فوق اراضيها وهذا الاعلان جاء
من بعد ما مواطنين شافوه فوق مونتانا وهذه
منطقه فيها قواعد عسكريه
ومستودعات الصواريخ نوويه تحت الارض
السلطات الامريكيه طلعت بعد بلاغات
المواطنين وقالت انها عارفه بوجود المنطاد
وانه رصد اول مره فوق الاسكا في 28 يناير
ويتحرك ودخل كندا في 30 الشهر ورجع المجال
الامريكي في واحد وثلاثين الشهر طيب ليه
ما اسقطوهم السلطات الامريكيه بتقول انه
من وقت مرصدته وهو ما رجع للمياه المفتوحه
وانه خافت تسقطه او تتعامل معه فوق مناطق
سكنيه المنطاد اللي بنتكلم عنه حجمه بحجم
ثلاثه حافلات يعني مدرسيه الصين طلعت
بعدها واعترفت انه المنطاد منطادها لكن
قالت انه مو عسكري بالاداء مدنيه
بيستخدموا لابحاث الارصاد الجويه وانه
انحرف عن مساره بسبب رياح غريبه واعتذرت
لامريكا عن انتهاك المنطاد لاجوائها لكن
هذه الروايه ما اقنعت امريكا لمصر ان
المنطاد هو المنطاد تجسس وبدانا نشوف
تصريحات اخذوا تاكيد وتكذيب الصين مصره
على كلامها وبتطالب امريكا بالهدوء وعدم
المبالغه فرد الفعل وامريكا مصره على
روايتها وامر بايدن باسقاط المنطاد كمان
وتم اسقاطه بالفعل يوم السبت فوق مياه
المحيط الاطلسي في عمليه شاركت فيها عده
طائرات
ومن بعد ما اسقطت واشنطن المنطاد طلع
بايدن ووجه التحيه للطيارين اللي اسقطوه
وقال انه هو امر او هو امر باسقاطه من يوم
الاربعاء وسبب التاخير الخوف على الناس
[موسيقى]
طلع اعلن انه حيجمع حطام المنطاد عشان
يعرفوا المعلومات اللي الصين جماعتها
الصين عصبت وطلعت ادانت واستنكرت التصرف
الامريكي باسقاط المنطاد وقالت انه كان رد
فعل مبالغ فيه وانه امريكا انتهت القوانين
الدوليه وانها بتحفظ بحق الرد وطلعت بعدها
من ساعات واعلنت اقاله مسؤول الارصاد
الجويه بسبب المنطاد الصيني وحملته
مسؤوليه الخطا اللي صار في تغيير مسار
المنطاد واختراقه للاجواء الامريكيه القصه
عامله طبعا ابعاد واخذ ورد واسئله
واستفسارات على كل الاصابع اولا داخل
امريكا في غضب خاصه من قبل الجمهوريين
اللي بيعتبروا اللي بيعتبروا اللي صار
اخفاق لاداره بايدون في حمايه الامن
القومي وشايفين كمان انه اداره بايدن
عارفه من زمان عن المنطاد وخبط الموضوع
علشان ما تبين اخفاقها هذا في المقابل
طبعا تم الاعلان عن الغاء زياره بلنكن
اللي كانت مقرره للصين وطلعت فجاه الصين
وقالت ما في زي اصلا اعلنا عنها وامريكا
تعلن براحتها فهنا صار في تساؤلات هل مثلا
في علاقه بين القصه اللي صارت هذه وبين
الزياره هل هي محاوله لالغائها مثلا من
احد الطرفين او طرف ثالث وفي طبعا السؤال
الاكبر التاني اللي هو روايه مين هي
الصحيحه يعني الصين بتقول منطاد بحثي وهذه
يعني روايه تتصدق لانه ليه مثلا ممكن
الصين تتجسس بمنطاد عند اقمار صناعيه كمان
كثيره هذا غير امريكا بنفسها اعترفت على
لسان مسؤول انه سبق ورصدت مناطيد صينيه
فوق امريكا اكثر من مره في السنوات
الماضيه وما عملت شيء امريكا وقتها في
الوقت نفسه في تحليلات تانيه بتقول لا
ممكن يكون للتجسس وتكون الصين بتتجسس
باقمار صناعيه
وبمناطيد كمان طيب غير كل هذا فكره اسقاط
المنطاد او فكره اسقاط امريكا لمنطقه صيني
واللي بالمناسبه هي اول حادثه اسقاط
للقوات الامريكيه لاي مركبه اجنبيه من وقت
الحرب العالميه الثانيه حادثه مثل هذه لاي
درجه خطيره وايش سبب خط هذه الاسئله راح
يجاوبنا عليها الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور احمد عجاج اهلا فيك معنا دكتور احمد
او الشيخ خلينا نبدا بالروايات المتعدده
والتحليلات اللي ماليه كل مكان يعني لو
تدخل على تويتر كل شخص جالس بحلله عنده
راي في الموضوع حضرتك
بخبرتك اجت الروايه التي تتوقع انها هي
الاصح
طبعا اذا كان يعني المنطاد هو للتجسس ام
لا او انه مجرد الاعصاب لا احد سيعرف الا
اذا تمكن الامريكيون من انتشال حطام
المنطاد لكني دعني يعني اعقد مقارنه بين
ذلك ان هناك حرب معلومات بين الصين وبين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحرب تجسس
قويه والمعلومات هي العنصر الاهم في
الانتصار في اي معركه ممكنه لذلك انا
اعتقد ان يمكننا ان نقارن بينما حدث مع
ابناء الاتحاد السوفيتي وامريكا عندما
ارسلت امريكا طائره لا يمكن اكتشافها
واسقطها الروس وعندما اسقطوها الروس قال
الامريكان انها مجرد الارصاد وللابحاث
وليست للتجسس لكن الروس امسكوا بالقائد
واظهروه على التلفاز واعترف بانه كان
يتجسس وعند ذلك اعترفت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه المنطاد ليس لديه يعني قائد
ليقوده لانه يتحرك بنفسه ولا يمكننا ان
نعرف لكن حطامه سيعطينا فرصه لنعرف ان كان
التجسس ام لا لكن دعيني اقول لك ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه منذ 2020 وهي
تطور تكنول التكنولوجيا المناطيد لانها
رخيصه جدا وتبقى في الفضاء لمده اشهر يعني
دون ان احد يعني يعتبر انها للتجسس لانها
مناطيد وبالتالي اسقاطها صعب جدا ايضا لان
كما رايتم في عرضتم في برنامجكم انها قد
تؤذي المواطنين لان عند اسقاطها تنبعث
منها غازات وحيطان وهي كبيره جدا لذلك
المناطيل هي حرب المستقبل القادمه لانها
رخيصه وتختلف عن الاقمار الصناعيه بكثير
لان الاقمار الصناعيه تمشي في مسار معين
ويمكن تتبعه اما المناطيط فقط تطورت مؤخرا
لدرجه انها بالحساب الرقمي يمكن ان تسير
وفق حركه الرياح فاذا كانت تريد ان تنزل
الى اسفل فانها تعد برمجه وتراقب حركه
الرياح وتسير في الطريق التي تريدها القوى
التي تحركها لذلك اعتقد الان لا يمكننا
الجزم بانها يعني تجسس وان كنت اميل الى
ذلك لكن لننتظر الحيطان طيب واسقاط امريكا
لها وغضب الصين من ذلك هل تعتقد انه حيكون
له تداعيات كبيره
طبعا الصين يعني كما تعرفي عندما لا طبعا
لن يكون له تداعيات لان الاسقاط تم في
اراضي امريكيه وهو اعتداء على السياده
الامريكيه وحتى الصينيون قالوا انهم يعني
لم يكونوا يقصدون ذلك وانما حدث خطا لكن
اسقاطه واسقاط ايضا للهيبه الصينيه يعني
هي من ناحيه معنويه لا اكثر ولا اقل ولكن
تداعيات الاسقاط هي مهمه جدا لان هناك نوع
من الانفراج الان بين الصين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وزياره بلينكن كانت
يعني مرحله انفتاح لانه لم يجر يعني احد
الصين منذ عام 2018 وياتي هذا المنطاد في
هذه اللحظه بالذات وعكر العلاقات وبالتالي
قطع بلينك زيارته للصين لكن دعيني اقول ان
قطع هذه الزياره او عدم اتمامها ليس
معناها انه لا يريد ان يتباحث مع الصين
انما لا يريد ان تكون زيارته كلها حول
البالون لانه اذا ذهب الان فكل الصحافي
يتحدثون عن البالون واسبابه وما وراءه
لذلك اعتقد انه اخرها لوقت اخر
تعتقد انه في اي احد من مصلحته كانت انه
مثلا يخرب هذه الزياره فاشتغل على هذا
الموضوع
طبعا طبعا يعني هناك في القياده الصينيه
العسكر والاجهزه الامنيه تحصل على ميزينات
ضخمه جدا ولا تريد اي يعني انفراج في
العلاقات لان اي انفراج في العلاقات سيؤدي
الى التوصل الى اتفقنا تقلص من التسابق في
التسلح وبالتالي التخلص ميزانيات العسكر
ولذلك قد يكون هناك يعني اجهزه داخل الجيش
الروسي الاجهزه الامنيه ارسلت هذا المنطاد
وقد لا يكون قد يكون بالخطا لذلك كل هذا
لا يمكن ان نعرفه الا لاحقا عندما تتكشف
اخبار كثيره لكن احتمال واسع ان هناك يعني
عناصر او اجنحه في القياده الصينيه تريد
تخريب هذه العلاقه وعدم حصول اي انفراج
وكذلك في امريكا كما ذكرتم ان هناك
جمهوريون يلومون الرئيس بيدا على تهاونه
ابن الصين مع انه تشدد اكثر من ترامب في
علاقاته مع الصين لكن السياسه تلعب دورها
في هذا المجال ولكن من الناحيه الامريكيه
كمان هل تعتقد انه مثلا يعني كمان كانت في
زي ما يقولوا ضغوطات علشان برضو هذه
الزياره ما تتم مش بس حتى من الجمهوريين
يعني من داخل الاداره ايضا كما تحدثت انه
مثلا من داخل الاداره الصينيه
طبعا يعني هناك يعني
صناعات ضخمه هائله وتحصل على الملايين
المليارات من الحكومه الامريكيه وقد تتضرر
هي الاخرى ايضا لذلك قد يكون لها مصلحه
ايضا في ذلك لكن بالنهايه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نعرف ان القرار شفاف
ويمكننا ان نعرف ماذا تتحدث عن الموضوع
لايام دكتور احمد هذا اللي زاد الشكوك نعم
نعم
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعترفت انها ليست
المره الاولى التي يعني تصل فيها مناطيت
صينيه الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن
هذه اول مره ينزل الى مستوى منخفض ويشاهده
الناس وهذا ما احرج الاداره الامريكيه
واضطرت الى يعني تطلق النار عليه وسبق
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان قامت
بالتجارب واطلقت يعني النار من صواريخ
1018 على منطاد
واسقطته لكن بقي سته ايام يعني الاجزاء
منه الغازات والاجهزه تنبعث لذلك كان خوف
القياده الامريكيه من ان اسقاطه قد يتسبب
في اضرار وهذا سيؤذن اكثر العلاقات بين
الصين وبين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لذلك انتظروا حتى يصل فوق البحر ويقع هناك
وبالتالي يستطيعون ان ياخذوا الحيطان من
البحر على العموم حنشوف ايش راح يصير كمان
في الايام الجايه بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور احمد عجاج شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد داليا فرهود شابه عراقيه
بلوجر او صانعه محتوى مختص بالموضه
والازياء عايشه في ليبيا وضجه المنصات
باسمها الايام الماضيه السبب بدايه كان
انباء عن اختفائها واللي جات بعد ايام بس
من اخبار مقتل البروجرام العراقي
طيبه علي على يد والدها في جريمه الشرف
لكن بعدين اتضحت الصوره اكثر لمن اعلن انه
داليا اختطفت من قبل جهه مسلحه مجهوله من
منزلها في مدينه جنزوري يوم الثلاثاء وبين
الروايات المتداوله روايه قالت ان له
علاقه بخلاف بينها وبين الاعلاميه الليبيه
غاليه ابو زعكوك مشتعل كان على المنصات
والروايه الثانيه قالت ان الموضوع له
علاقه بمحتوى داليا اللي وصفوه بانه لا
يتناسب مع المجتمع الليبي والد الداليه
طلعت للاعلام ونفت علاقه الاعلاميه
الليبيه باختطاف بنتا وقالت انه جهه مسلحه
تابعه للجهاز الردع التابع لو الداخليه هم
اللي خطفوا بنتها من بعد مداهموا البيت
يوم الثلاثاء من دون امر تفتيش او قبض
وفتشوا غرفه داليا ومن بعدها اخذوها وقالت
انه ثاني يوم بنتها تواصلت معاها وقالت
لها انه هي بخير وحققوا معاها وراح توقع
على اقوالها وتطلع ولكن من يوم الاربعاء
فقدت التواصل مع بنتها وما عاد عرفت عنه
اي معلومات ومن بعد هذه الاتهامات طلع
المتحدث باسم جهاز الردع في تصليحات او في
تصريحات للاعلام ونفى انه داليا مقتطفه
وقال انها محتجزه لدى الجهه المختصه بتهمه
نشر محتوى ما بيناسب المجتمع الليبي بحسب
وصفهم اما بالنسبه للسلطات العراقيه
للامنا شدتهم بيتدخلوا يكون بنتها مواطنه
عراقيه فوكاله الانباء العراقيه نشرت نقلا
عن المتحدث باسم الخارجيه تاكيد ان
الوزاره بتتابع القصه باهتمام
اعجب سطو مسلح في التاريخ واغبى حراميه
كده وصف اردنيين واقعه وابطالها يعني
فيديوهاتهم ما شاء الله منوره الاردنيين
كلهم وحتى طبعا تخطط حدود الاردن ووصلت
للعرب كلهم الموضوع كله بدا بفيديو من
كاميرات مراقبات محل الصرافه بنشوف اثنين
داخلين يسوقوا المحل
متخيلين طبعا يعني ردات الفعل على
الكوميديا اللي حصلت يعني ما ينفع نسمي
هذا السطور مسلح اصلا يعني الاثنين دخلوا
هددوا الموظفين بمسدس بلاستيك ما استجاب
الموظفين قاموا حرقوا المحل وطلعوا تخيلوا
عادل المشهد لما انتشرت مقاطع اضافيه من
الكاميرا اللي بره وفيها عاد لحظات الدخول
والخروج كمان
شوفوا بالله طلعت الاثنين من المحل كيف
كانت
[موسيقى]
الموسيقى من عندنا مو من المقطع بس احنا
حسينا انه لازم نضيفه من كثر الدراما
شفناها في المقطع طيب من فين ابدا حقيقه
ولا بالفعل يعني من دخله الوحش اللي دخلها
على الباركينج وكيف وقف نظامي وفي نص
الشارع ولا من اللبس ان كان من الفروه
للسائق لابسها واللي واضح انها اثقل منه
ولا الشماغ على وجهه الثاني اللي طاح بعد
عشر ثواني وانكشفت هويته ولا من الكيس
اللي كان كده بكيس بلاستيك بيحط فيه
الملايين
ولا من اللياقه الخرافيه وزحلقت الاثنين
وهم طالعين
مشهد كوميدي متكامل والاردنيين طبعا ما
قصروا تعليق عليه ترى والتعليقات الابرز
فين مافيات ايطاليا عن هذه المواهب الفذه
للعلم بس الامن العام الاردني اعلن بعد
القبض عليهم بس للامانه الاثنين لازم
ينحبسوا بتهمه الغباء قبل اي تهمه ثانيه
لانه حقيقه مو معقول ابدا اللي شفناه نحن
في هذا المقطع
[موسيقى]
طيب خبرنا الجي يمكن يبدو عادي بس تفاصيله
فعلا عجيبه السلطات الاندونيسيه بتحارب
التسول بس مو هذا هو العجيب في الخبر اكيد
العجيب هو تكمله العنوان السلطات
الاندونيسيه قالت انه بتحارب التسول اون
لاين وهنا عاد السؤال
هذا عارفينه في الشوارع في الاماكن العامه
وغيرها بس ايش هذا التسول اون لاين اتضح
يا جماعه انه في ترند في اندونيسيا
والترند احنا قررنا نسميه التسول في زمن
تيك توك والترند ببساطه هو انه مواطنين
بيفتحوا لايفات على تيك توك وبيبداوا
يطلبوا من الناس اللي بيتفرجوا عليهم انهم
يبعتوا لهم جوائز الجوائز هذه ميزه يعني
ما يعرف ولو فاتح لايف الناس ممكن تبعث لك
هدايا وهذه الهدايا بتتحول فلوس
[موسيقى]
ريماس دنيا
وما صار الموضوع بس ناس جالسه وبتترجل
متابعين انه يبعتوا لهم هدايا لا الموضوع
صار انه بيعرضوا على المتابعين انه يعملوا
تصرفات عجيبه مقابل الهدايا وابرز المطالب
هي انه يستحموا بالطين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا
عد والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده
من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]